I've been working on this series for
National Geographics I've been traveling
around the world searching
for these people that do incredible
Feats that they've passed down through
generations and I'm trying to learn but
it's a fast learning curve so it is the
most dangerous thing that I've ever done
in my life but I have the best of the
best helping so that says a lot cuz
you've done by far the most yes whoa
well you show me some things off camera
that we can't talk about about but well
you can talk about him I just can't show
it well um so the scariest thing was
like three days ago i k a king cobra
yeah I saw in the wild yeah what is is
there a trick to that is there um is it
a movement thing do you move slowly so
you don't I studied for weeks and just
tried to understand their behavior and
worked with different cobras and and was
I had a team around me that that taught
me how to to move quickly and get out of
the way what happens if you get
bit well they have enough Venom to kill
a full grown elephant in 30 minutes so
we had antivenom we had that there but
but still in my case I don't trust that
and even if you get antivenom it's still
a rough ride even if you live right yeah
is it similar it was amazing it was
incredible is it similar to rattlesnake
venom cuz rattlesnake venom essentially
like neuro yeah I mean digests your body
this this one
shuts everything down so your heart your
lungs everything just start to so were
they like ready on standby with a needle
well they don't they put it in a serum
you have to go to a hospital we go to
hospital yeah so you have to travel but
we had an ambulance right there and how
far is the hospital it was 20 minutes
away oh God so 20 minut pink oh God so
20 minutes of King Cobra
Venom scariest and most intense thing
I've ever done
yeah how many of these guys die doing
this well the the snake we the two
snakes we had one of them killed its
previous previous owner oh boy yeah and
they don't kill snake after it kills the
previous own this guy died so exactly
right that's
right oh boy it's it's but it
is kind of incredible
cuz you there's another guy named Chris
sweet who um well that's his Instagram
name but he lives in Thailand with 90
venomous snakes and he just lets them
move through his legs through he's well
he was bitten twice on my birthday and
his heart stopped two times but he lets
him just while you were there no no no
no on April 4th I mean oh okay yeah but
he but he's so calm with them and he
studies their behavior and he watches
how they move and then he gently takes
them out and there was one we were
outside and the scariest thing wasn't
trying to kiss it
exactly and I think that's a snake
called a Spire yeah so that that's one
that was slithering through my legs and
you have to keep your heart rate
down cuz if they sense they have
phermones they detect if you're nervous
or uncomfortable so anytime I would get
like super tense I would have to I'd
walk away carefully oh boy yeah that's
him and that's yep that's a snake called
a Spire it has you're so good at finding
everything
wow oh my God it's trying to bite you
through the
glass why is it trying to bite you
through the glass but won't try to bite
you when you're right there well there
it's feeding oh when it smells snake or
food it becomes aggressive so you have
to make sure you don't smell like any
other snakes or anything or food what
kind of food they eat snakes the king
cobras they eat other snakes yeah not
not king cobras but other snakesnakes
yeah
dude
okay do you have a second guess when
you're about to do something like this
that one I second guessed I left I left
and then came back a few months later
and did it again I wouldn't go I was too
afraid to go near it what made you go
back I went to Cleveland and I train
with my friend Mike and my other friend
Chris Gillette who's gator boy Chris
who's amazing and we slowly started to
understand just a little bit of the
behavior of king cobras and then I went
back to Indonesian trained with Fitz
who's unbelievable with how he handles
the cobras and slowly I felt okay but
there was days I wouldn't even do
anything so luckily I had a week which
is still a really fast learning curve
yeah normally I would train for
something for a year but with this show
I get like a few days and then I have to
try to do
it oh
boy so what strategies you using to keep
your heart rate low like when if you
feel yourself freaking out how do you
calm yourself down I I get out you just
get out yeah yeah just get out and
regroup
yeah yeah
David but that's the last dangerous
thing I'm going to do like that ever
that's it ever yeah yeah yeah like that
yeah well I'm glad you're alive and I
feel like in my I did in my show in
Vegas I was jumping from uh like the
height of a nine-story building Landing
in boxes and I dislocated my shoulder it
came down to my
armpit but in retrospect I think I was
lucky because that could have been
really bad it could have been the neck
it could have been something else oh
yeah so did you get surgery no I didn't
get the surgery what they did just there
was an orthopedic surgeons convention in
Vegas at that time so I had five
orthopedic surgeons in the off in the
audience and one was a shoulder
specialist and he they all came on stage
and they and he popped it right back in
so then I walked out to do the show Joe
with but but I my arm was all numb it
stayed numb for like two months but I
was going like this to get like to see
if I could get feeling back and it fell
back out so I had to go back on stage
they popped it back in and then I did
the whole show with one
arm yeah that's it yeah that's a bad one
I think that's the one I got injured
yeah and my friend Doug who's with the
hat right there he when I jumped he knew
that something was going to go wrong he
bent over and took a heavy breath cuz he
knew that was the
one there's a a gentleman named Yuri
prasa he was the UFC light heavyweight
champion and his shoulder dislocated
during training and his trainers tried
to pop it back into place and they were
yanking on it and they just destroyed
his shoulder they tore everything apart
just kind of pulling on it and it ripped
apart they the UFC doctor said it was
the worst shoulder injury you'd ever
seen that's crazy and he's fighting
again next weekend got it repaired he
got surgery yep got surgery vacated his
title and now he's back fighting for the
title next weekend yeah mine is still
messed up really yeah like in what way
well I haven't I can't really work out
or do anything the same way how long ago
uh
maybe March did you get an MRI oh many
MRIs what is what's the damage no it was
really bad I ripped through the
ligaments I it was bad it came down to
here right why didn't they do surgery I
didn't I'm like afraid of surgery I have
to say like horrified of it why you
afraid of surgery I don't know you're
not afraid of King Cobra's view yeah
it's crazy but I'm horrified of surgery
why I don't
know